you always want to try and find people
that are ahead of you because they're
the ones that are going to bring you
along if you're a rocket ship that's
taking off at 10,000 m/s and someone
else is moving at 100 m/ second there's
only a small while before you're very
far away from them and it's hard to have
conversations about things because the
things that you're struggling with are
different to the things that they're
struggling with and the dreams and the
goals that you have have now outgrown
the dreams and the goals that they have
trying to find people who match your
personal growth velocity is really hard
that's not to say that they can't even
catch you up and then maybe overtake you
in future they very well may do but it's
going to be tough for you to find common
ground unless that person's very open
and honest and unless you are too in
order to be able to do that show me your
friend group I'll show you your future